what's up
guys
um I'm actually looking I'm looking at
the comments right now and scrolling
through
here a lot of people are just like he's
coming in 30 seconds it's actually be a
little bit earlier than that like a few
seconds early but by the time you guys
see this won't
matter oh
man at least I think it should be
starting
soon this guy's probably
asleep where are people convinced I'm
asleep come on there we go there we go
right on time
too oh oh man this delay is going to
trip people
out oh
man all
right it's weird like looking at YouTube
because I'm I'm looking at YouTube right
now and I'm seeing myself but it's like
I'm not hearing anything return oh my
God there's
sound why am I hearing sound what's up
guys
um I'm actually looking I'm looking at
the comments right now and scrolling
through here oh god there was that one
that was open it's going to get really
like really [__] up here in a second
oh man I had it open a two windows okay
so now that I know what I'm doing so
let's go back let's go back and look at
the
comments okay so yes I play
guitar uh the poster behind me is John
Lennon
actually um it actually has a
lyrics it has a lyrics for a song on
there you have to guess which song it is
uh yeah I need to start putting the the
songs in
there I mean we're talking about delay
of maybe I don't know 30 seconds or
so oh
man it's 5:00 a.m. wow over here in
America it's 6 o'cl in the evening 600
p.m. people are like oh it's fine now
it's good now it's good now and it's
like oh my gosh it's getting
crazy yeah this delay is killing me okay
so so let's let's scroll back up because
a lot of you guys asked a lot of
questions earlier like much earlier well
either that or you guys were talking
about crazy
stuff
like Superman versus all the entities of
emotion who will
win uh
emotion see I'm not that vers in DC I
assume that's like an actual character
like emotions as an actual character
favorite Marvel
movie o um yes those are the lyrics to
imagine U my favorite Marvel movie is
definitely Captain America the Winter
Soldier I would
say actually the guitar case is empty
that's what houses the guitar over there
I just uh I just haven't moved it yet I
need
to if I had one mustache from Marvel who
would it be General Ross H yeah it would
no no I'm not thinking of that I'm
thinking of um whose mustache am I
thinking of nobody has a good mustache
in the Marvel Marvel Cinematic Universe
now that I think about it he shreds his
ax Goku or new Superman definitely Goku
hands down
Goku yeah chat's going nuts uh what's
your favorite Iron Man armor
um
H I would say the original Iron Man
armor in the comics like the the giant
metal like gray armor cuz to me it just
looked it looks kind of cool like I
think it looks pretty
awesome I mean at the very least he's
just walking around as a giant gray
metal
robot how could that be a bad thing Rob
what is the meaning of
life uh I have no idea what the mean of
life is I have no
clue I mean if you watch if you ever
read Hitcher guy to the Galaxy the life
in the universe and everything equals 42
so whether you believe that or not I
think is a whole different thing but
nonetheless Iron Man is better than oh
wow Winter Soldier you think
so did he keep the mustache when he's
Red Hulk no he lost the mustache when he
was Red Hulk although it would be
awesome to see Red Hulk with a
mustache who do you think is the
stupidest mainstream Marvel character
besides Spider-Man o that's a tough
one uh there are some goofy mainstream
Marvel characters out there but anyway
before we get into all that before we
start getting like while these questions
are propagating let's get into the
giveaway all right
so I was trying to figure out what to
get you guys because we're going to
break 150,000 subscribers we're not
there yet but we'll break it within the
next day or so and I was like you know
what is what's something I should get
people for 150,000 subscribers because a
lot of you guys have been really patient
like when I've been trying new things
and experimenting because here's the
deal I don't want to get boxed into
making like 20-minute videos I mean
ultimately this is my channel and I
should be able to produce whatever kind
of content I want to produce as long as
it's comic book related because this is
a channel based on comic books and so um
a lot of you guys have been really
supportive when I was doing like the
three minute challenge a lot of you guys
are really supportive I need some
water a lot of you guys are really
supportive when I was asking you know do
I want to if I can you know I guess if
really Star Wars would be a good
direction to go in different things like
that you know a lot of you guys have
been really supportive there and and I
think that needs to be rewarded I think
that the supportive guys need to be
rewarded now of course I can't give
something to everybody like I can't give
something away to every single person
but I'm I'm looking at all the questions
as they're going
through
but I wanted to give something away and
my initial thought was what can I give
away you know if I can't give something
to everyone I should be able to get one
person something but it should be really
really good and so I thought about like
a comic book but I can't just get like a
comic book I actually went to comic
comic interlude which is where I go to
get my comic books here in town and they
had like all the good Comics you know of
course in the back the ones that are
worth a ton of money they had like uh
the first appearance a black panther
they wanted like 500 bucks for it you
know um they had all these really really
cool these really cool comics and I
thought you know Comics would be cool
but I can't just get one comic you know
I have to get more than one comic and if
I get more than one comic then why not
just get an Omnibus and so uh I'm really
dragging this out I'm really trying to
lay this on thick and so what I did is I
went through my YouTube videos and
looked at the most popular videos that I
have and the the most popular series
that I have is Civil War but we all know
what Civil War is like Civil War would
be you know it seemed like it wouldn't
really matter at this point I mean
everybody knows what Civil War it's most
everybody's read it and so on and so
forth and so I said okay what's my most
popular
video and my most popular video is
Deadpool and so okay let's get something
Deadpool related and so I figur you know
let's get like a Deadpool Omnibus and so
here's here's what I
got man I don't know if you guys can see
this but I went out and got the Deadpool
and cable Omnibus all right this
collects the entire Deadpool and cable
run issues 1 through 50 and I figured
you guys would be over the moon for
something like
this and so I'm going to give it to one
of you
guys now this thing's heavy I mean I
mean look how thick this thing is like
look at
that
so this automatically gets upload
uploaded to YouTube by the
way so
um so what do you have to do to win it
you know what do you have to do to win
this Deadpool and cable
Omnibus all you have to do is just be
here that's all you have to do is just
be
here I'm actually looking I'm I'm I'm
gonna pause for a minute I want to see
what people
say so Deadpool and cable
people think it's pretty
awesome wow that's awesome
Rob so anyway so um I'm going to give
this away at the end of the whole Q&A
because I think that other people are
going to like kind of trickle in as time
goes on and so on and I want them to be
able to have the opportunity to win this
thing so um so I don't want to leave
people out but yeah this this thing this
thing is massive I thought see here was
here was the deal I thought initially
like of getting like the Infinity
Gauntlet thing you know but The Infinity
Gauntlet is really really old and I
thought about doing you know like I I
don't know there were other ones that
were crossing my mind and actually the
Civil War one is huge like it's massive
and I was like you know everybody seems
to love Deadpool like a lot of people
seem to love Deadpool and so I was like
I guess we'll go with Deadpool and I
figured Deadpool and cable would be
awesome like people love people love
Deadpool so I mean why not do Deadpool
and cable but anyway so let let the
questions roll in um like let's let's go
back up here and see what people are are
saying Superman versus The Avengers who
would win uh Superman would easily beat
all the Avengers and here's why the
Avengers it was it's enough for them to
take on the Incredible Hulk and while
the Incredible Hulk gets stronger the
angrier he gets like Superman's just
strong right off the bat and he's got a
multitude of abilities at his disposal
so I think he'd be able to take down the
Avengers single-handedly I mean he's got
abilities like extend beyond you know
like his physical like he can shoot
lasers out of his eyes and stuff like
that you know heat vision and so on so
he he'd be I think he'd take out the
Avengers the only person that would
really stand a chance against him with
regards to the Avengers would probably
be the incredible
H now I would say that Superman could be
taken down by Marvel characters and not
even reality warping characters just
like super strong characters like he
could be taken down by the Red Hulk uh
Savage Hulk and the Sentry if they
combine their forces then they could
probably take Superman down pretty
easily but uh but yeah I don't know
let's see
the Marvel unlimited subscription was
actually a really good idea I should
have gone with that that would have been
cool I robbed a comic
shop uh let's see okay let's let's
scroll back down and see what kind of
questions did we
get you should do a video on the Prelude
of all the Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies and how they tie together we are
like we're going to do that I'm actually
thinking about cuz I know the Prelude
just came out a few days ago for Age of
Ultron and uh spoiler alert it pretty
much like tells us what's going on with
Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch and so
I'm thinking about just doing like a
video explaining that whole concept like
what's going on with Quicksilver and the
squad witch because what Marvel did
because of their announcement in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the comics
they came back and they make Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch uh Inhumans and so
that's really going to kind of tie in
but um let's see oh God questions are
coming in so
fast what about Superman versus the
centy um that is argument that will go
on until the end of time people because
the century or even Hyperion like see
here's here's the deal DC's got Superman
and there's only one one like real
Superman in DC's continuity I would say
there's different versions of him but in
terms of like what encompasses Superman
they all pretty much have around the
same abilities unless you're talking
about like Superman Prime or something
like that but um Marvel has a bunch of
different versions of Superman they've
got Hyperion they've got blue Marvel
they've got the century um a Superman
versus the century I mean at the end of
the day the centur is really strong but
he's on the same level as the Incredible
Hulk and when it comes down to it I
would say that when when the conflict's
over that Superman I think would be able
to last longer than the century would so
I'd say Superman would probably
win uh let's
see uh the guitar in the background is a
Gibson
guitar do imag him Jasper
explain I'm not going to play Imagine on
the
guitar how would I reboot marel that's a
good question how would I reboot Marvel
oh yes um by the way yes we are going to
be doing a video on Daredevil and we'll
talk about the Daredevil trailer here in
a second because if you if you if you
know the Daredevil continuity you know
exactly what era they're drawing this
this content from but nonetheless
um what what was it we said we were oh
yeah rebooting Marvel um I would wipe
the Slate clean we talked about this
during the podcast yesterday with with
comic cast or Comic Book C with Joel and
arming and I would wipe the Slate Clint
I'd start from zero like I would take
this whole battle World thing and
basically say like the entire continuity
is starting over and it would be year
zero for Marvel Comics and so you know
this summer is the First Time Peter
Parker ever gets bitten by radioactive
spider and it all goes forward from
there that would be my that' be the way
I'd do it I just start completely over
like Marvel's new or DC's New 52 except
that I would reboot the continuity of
everybody I wouldn't reboot the
continuity of only some people but
um let's see
can you play us to get play us a song on
your I'm not going to play anything on
my
guitar uh okay so
Daredevil so again we're going to do a
video on Daredevil like we're going to
do a daredevil explained um but here's
here's the
deal if you went back and if you if you
knew a whole lot about the the dear
devil continuity you know that like a
lot of different things came in with
Daredevil like a lot of different
writers came in like you originally had
Stan Lee Jack Kirby you had Jack Kirby
that took off after a while you had um
Jean colen I think you had Steve Gerber
you had a lot of guys that came in and
wrote for Daredevil but it wasn't until
1979 when Frank Miller showed up that
Daredevil was completely revamped he
totally changed Daredevil again we'll
get into this in our video but with
Daredevil he made Daredevil a much
darker character
and that seems to be the Daredevil that
we're going to see in the Netflix series
it looks like we're going to see Frank
Miller's Daredevil which I'm actually
really excited about because again it
was a gritty Daredevil it was a dark
Daredevil and I thought that was
freaking awesome like he tried to kill a
guy like he actually like yeah he he
threw a guy off the top of a building
like it was pretty awesome uh yeah Miles
Morales is really popular people love
Miles
Morales uh who is Raina in Agents of
Shield Season 2 okay there is an inhuman
I think I think is an inhuman literally
named Raina and uh she she's like she
looks like a feline like a cat kind of
but not really it's kind of weird to
describe how she looks but that looks
like that's who Raina is going to be and
the reason why is because if you go back
and you watch season 2 Agents of Shield
you see that uh Sky cocoon isn't the
only one that cracks that I think
actually right right after Skies or even
right before somewhere around that time
when the cocoons first start cracking
that um one of the cocoons around the
orbital sockets of one of them the
Cocoon cracks like the actual uh the
solid matter cracks and it looks like
it's got like a tiger's eye or like a
feline eye and that's probably Raina so
I would say that it changed their
physical form into something else which
kind of sucks because the chick that
played Raina was pretty damn hot
so Superman versus Silver Surfer
definitely Superman Silver Surfer is
powerful but he's not Superman
powerful uh will they call the new what
would they call the new age of the
reboot I mean this is Marvel's new
continuity I'd say it's probably they
probably be like all new Marvel Comics
or something like that I think is what
they would call it that that's what
would make sense to me
uh let's
see who's your favorite underused Marvel
character which character do you feel
Marvel needs to use more
often o um Phil Coulson and here's a
funny thing we're going to do a video on
Phil Coulson too but Phil Coulson I
think Joel and army again said it really
really good last time they said that
like Phil Coulson was us as like the
fans you know the he was those of us who
like jumped in and wanted to see um like
all these different characters and stuff
like that and again like we we we'll tie
into all this when we get into our Phil
Coulson video because Phil Coulson was
actually introduced in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and then he showed up
in battle scars and then he had a
limited run
in uh no he had a pretty big run in
Secret Avengers Volume 2 and then um and
then now he's in the shield solo series
or the shield series um all new Shield I
guess it is or all Marvel Now Shield or
whatever it is but it's a new run
basically and um it features him and the
Agents of Shield it's basically like the
comic book tie-ins to the TV show which
fills in the gaps which is actually
pretty good I think we're on issue
number two right now and issue number
three comes out next month but um it's
pretty cool like it's a it's a pretty
cool Series so far but I definitely want
to see like more Phil Coulson in the
comics but uh let's see who who do you
think will win in a fight Wonder Woman
or
Thor
uh I don't
know I mean Wonder Woman we can't call
the weather but she's got like her lasso
of Truth and her Invincible bands or
whatever it is and Thor can call on the
weather he's well he doesn't even have M
anymore so that's a huge disadvantage
are we talking about lady Thor or we are
you talking about like pre- lady Thor
like Odin sun because that's how I'm
going to distinguish the two of them
from from now on like I call the old
Thor Odin son and the new Thor Thor and
so I don't know if that's what you're
referring
to repost of my earlier question what is
the reason why I read Comics why do you
keep reading comics comics are I mean to
me Comics are like are my my version of
like fiction like fiction novels like
some people read non-fiction novels they
love reading about the world for example
um there are some people like there's a
really really good book if you want to
study World War II history read the rise
and fall of the Third Reich that's uh
it's the book's like that thick it's
massive but it'll tell you everything
you need to know about the rise and fall
of Nazi Germany and some people love
that stuff I read some of that stuff you
know some people love um non-fiction I'm
sorry fiction books they love you know
Harry Potter which I love Harry Potter
books to take off out of nowhere you
know for me I always loved comic books I
always loved the idea of superheroes
people with powers stuff like that what
would they do with those powers and so
on and so that's that's why I read
that's why I always read comic books
um let's
see scroll down some
more if you could make a movie about any
Marvel character which one would you
choose the century I'd pick uh Paul
jings and Jay's run of Marvel Knights
and I would make that into a movie it'd
be it'd be a standalone movie it would
never tie in to the rest of the Marvel
continuity it'd be totally isolated and
it would not be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe just like Marvel
Knights was not part of the main stream
Marvel continuity um the centy would be
totally isolated in and of itself and I
think it would be awesome like it would
have to be it have to be good but it
have to be dark like it have to be done
really gritty and it have to be done by
a serious director it could be
action-packed it couldn't be a Jos
Sweden movie it's not to say Jos Sweden
is not a serious director he's a great
director but it would have to be by
someone who can make dark but serious
toned films so I probably try to get
like Clint Eastwood to direct it I think
it'd be awesome it'd be dark could be
dramatic just like the comics were but
um let's
see uh your favorite Marvel character
versus a DC character who would win okay
mad Jim Jaspers versus some money from
DC all right here's a kicker when it
comes to Mad Jim Jaspers and a lot of
people ask me this question who would
win mad Jim Jaspers or Franklin Richards
all right here's the deal Marvel
established
in I guess Daredevil's Issue Number 10
or whatever it was when when um mad Jim
Jaspers died I can't remember maybe it
was the mighty world of Marvel issue
number something anyway it crossed like
three Marvel prints and that's why the
Crooked world was such a pain in the ass
story to follow like imagine well I
guess it was pretty primitive it happens
now but like back then yeah anyway it
doesn't matter um the fact remains that
Marvel established the fact that mad Jim
Jaspers has to have reality in order to
warp that reality basically he has to
have the clay in front of him he can't
just make the clay he can't just imagine
the clay into existence and then mold it
accordingly and so anybody who can warp
reality but doesn't need reality
immediately has an upper hand on Jim
Jaspers they immediately uh have more
power than he does but that only counts
if they travel to a location where there
is no reality as soon as they developed
some kind of reality then he could
immediately manipulate it and begin
using it accordingly so it's kind of
difficult you know with with Jim Jaspers
to have him conflict with people but
um I would say that that Jim Jaspers
versus I don't know Superman Prime that
would be a cool video or a cool a cool
discussion to see I
think uh do I read any independent
Comics the only Indie Comics that I
really stick to are The Walking Dead
that's really it that was that was
that's really the only Indie Comics that
really res ated with me but again I
don't I don't really go into in depth
with a lot of Indie Comics
so why is my voice so soothing I don't
know you tell
me uh let's see is it possible for the
Red Hulk to wield a red power ring what
would
happen
H I mean are you talking about the rings
from the Green Lantern like the lantern
rings I don't know what red power ring
you're talking
about
uh Star Wars plus Earth equals Sith
versus
Avengers uh I mean are you talking about
like a crossover
between
like the Sith and the Star Wars
continuity like crossing over into the
Marvel I guess the mainstream Earth 616
continuity and fighting the Avengers
because I'm down to see that [__] like
I'd love to see that my pet would be a
dog I used to have a cat but he ran
away
how do you have enough time to do all
these videos I make the time although
I'm terrible with time management I'm
getting a lot better at it but I'm
terrible with time management so uh yeah
like Benny and sa will tell you like Rob
sucks with time
management so are you watching enjoying
Agent Carter Agent Carter is not bad um
initially it took some time to grow on
me uh it took some time to uh to really
I guess impact me I'm I'm going to set
this uh this thing right here so people
can see it and they can know that this
is what I'm giving away but um Agent
Carter took some time to to actually
like grow on me it took some time to
like to become interesting because my
biggest fear was that with Agent Carter
what it was going to be with just this
story where she was just she was
metaphorically defeating like the
oppression of of a patriarchal society
by always fighting men you know and to
me like that's a pain in the ass it's
like always being reminded that racism
exists in the world like we know it's
there we know that there are gender
stereotypes we know that women don't get
a fair rap all the time I don't need it
thrown in my face and I certainly don't
want to see it when I want to break away
from The Real World by watching a show
based on a fictional character you know
and that that's what I was afraid it was
going to be I think that that Marvel's
kind of breaking away from that I think
they were that initially they were kind
of like okay this could be a good basis
for it but I think people just kind of
got annoyed with it after a while you
know even though we're only a couple
episodes in but um I think that
ultimately like I think that as time
progresses I mean it's only a few
seasons or only a few episodes it's only
like six episodes I think that once it
really becomes like a full series cuz I
think it will um that they'll be able to
add a lot more continuity to it and make
it a lot more diverse in terms of what
it is that she's doing because honestly
I'm tired of seeing her beat up guys all
the time because I would hope that
there's a lot more to the dynamic nature
of Sharon of Agent Carter of agent Peggy
Carter then basically being a feminist
beating up men like if that's really all
she stands for then her character
doesn't stand for a lot
so
uh knowing the Marvel lineup
do you think Adam Warlock or Beta Ray
Bill will ever show up in the MCU yes
Adam Warlock is going to show up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I would bet
money on it I would bet all the money at
my pockets to all the money in your
pockets that he will be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we know that because
it's cocoon broke now whether or not
Beta Ray Bill will be in there I don't
know I
mean if Marvel's basically going the
direction of combining the comics or of
having the movies influence the comics
would they which they are regardless of
what they say then I would say that most
likely bet Ray Bill uh may make an
appearance in there just simply because
of the fact that he was the only I guess
the first person to be able to wield
Thor's hammer and he's got a really
significant role in the history of
continuity he's really just been like a
Legacy character like he showed up and
he was like I can pick up you know um I
can pick up Odin's son's hammer and
people were like oh my God that's
amazing now and so because of that he's
always got a special spot in the hearts
of Marvel Comics fans everywhere even if
he's a character who's not wildly
relevant like he shows up during
Ragnarok he's like you know he's like
Thor like combat brother I've have I've
answered your distress call or whatever
it is I can't remember exactly what he
says but
um uh do you think a Killing Joke
animated movie would
be could I guess cool yeah I'd love to
see a Killing Joke animated
movie
um do you think that Captain the Captain
Marvel movie will tie in with the
Avengers Infinity war movie um yeah it's
all related like it's all one big thing
like that's that's what it is I think I
can I think I can sit that book there
for right
now I mean Marvel's explicitly told us
that the uh all the Marvel Cinematic uh
Marvel Cinematic Universe films tieing
together like you guys got to keep in
mind when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Agent Carter the
Inhumans um as we've seen them so far
with like Sky um Agents of Shield um all
the movies that have come into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they're all in
the they're all in one the same Contin
they're all taking place at around the
same time you I mean of course there's
differences with Captain America which
took place you know initially during
World War II and stuff like that but
nonetheless like these are all they're
all in the same continuity they're all
in the same universe and so like I
definitely think that that you know um
Captain Marvel will tie into the
infinity war movie I mean I think she'll
be in the infinity war movie so unless
it no it comes it comes before the
infinity war movie I think I'm pretty
sure
um how would you fix change the current
X-Men I don't even know where to begin
with that
one uh okay b r Bill people say he was
saved by the one above all but we don't
know that all we know is that he
supposedly died it's from The Saga of
bet Ray Bill I know what you're talking
about um it's a six-part series we don't
know if it was the one above all it's
just some Heavenly Voice or something
like that that speaks to ra bet Ray Bill
people think it is there's really no
other reason to think it's not but we
just don't know for a fact that that's
true uh am I excited for the new Gambit
definitely like I love gavit as a
character as long as they stay true to
his roots in the sense that he's like a
I don't
know like a scoundrel basically in terms
of how he acts I really hope they they
get into the idea of like his actual
like you know in the in-depth nature of
who he was you know as part of like when
they get into like the Thieves Guild and
all that kind of like the expanded lore
I guess of gambut when they get more in
depth into his character I wonder if
they're actually going to add in like
the idea of the mutant Massacre or if
it's just going to be some crappy
version of Gambit I don't know um the
flavor Vape that I have right now is
cloud science and this one's called
gamma Cloud science gamma is actually
really good it's like a peach a peach uh
pineapple flavor it's it's freaking
amazing
uh okay since they have to include the
time gy which MCU film would you prefer
to see the time travel plot
in O I don't know I mean I'm not big on
time travel plots because I think it's
like a cheap way out um I honestly don't
think that here's here's what I hope
would happen I don't think they'll
actually use the time gy to travel back
in time I think they might use it to
travel forward in time and they might
use it as a way to bring an end to the
Civil War conflict they might you know
Captain America might pursue the time
gym or somebody might have the time gy
and they jump forward like a 100 years
and like oh my God the the Earth has
been destroyed because of the Civil War
conflict like the superheroes have
basically like wrecked the Earth like
the entire planet is in a state of
desolation like I think they might use
something like that go back in time and
say you guys got to stop this and here's
why and they're like okay cool I guess
we'll do that but I don't I don't know
um pre rcon molecule Man versus The
Living Tribunal o that is a good one
because remember PR rcon when uh PR rcon
molecule man he was able to exist across
different dimensions like his fight with
the beyonder jumped across different
dimensions in uh in Secret Wars issue uh
Secret Wars part two volume two um I
think the Living Tribunal still has it
but I don't
know
uh let's
see thoughts on Fox's new Fantastic 4
movie trailer I don't know at this point
it's really too early to tell but given
Fox's history with the Fantastic 4
trailers and with or the Fantastic 4
Films with Benny saying that uh I think
it was Benny saying that fox had already
canceled fantastic 42 because they
thought that fantastic 41 was going to
do terrible uh I don't think it's going
to be that
good
um you think Deadpool is going to be a
good movie Yes actually Ryan Reynolds
had recently done an interview I think
where he had talked about the director
he was directing the movie now and he
said that he's hoping for a rated R
movie and he thinks the director's done
a fantastic job and I think that's huge
news because Ryan Reynolds was the one
who was pushing for a Deadpool movie of
course he's the perfect person to play
Deadpool and um and he's he's going to
he's one of these guys I think where
where once he stepped into the role of
Deadpool with uh X-Men Origins wol rain
the fans were just like he's the only
person needs to play Deadpool which I
agree but they were like no one else
needs to play Deadpool besides Ryan
Reynolds he's goofy he's kind of out
there but he's still cool and he's you
know he a person that can be serious
when he needs to be and so on and so
forth but um but I don't know um but
yeah I think from what he said and
interviews and stuff the movie is going
to be really really good like it's going
to be what fans want to see in a
Deadpool movie whether it's going to be
r at R we don't know but I would hope it
is
so uh Loki scepter the mind gy yes or no
yes yes Loki scepter is the Mind gym or
at least it houses the mind gy or I'm
sorry um yeah uh the Mind gem what gems
do we have so far we have the Tess R
okay it could be either the Mind gem or
the space or the soul gem but we have
the
um the
Tesseract the the Tesseract is the Space
Gem The Ether is a reality gem um the
power Gem and then whichever one the um
the that was in the staff of Loki this
justs like Harry Potter like you
remember Harry Potter like when it came
around to like the sixth book and
everybody who was a Harry Potter fan was
speculating and they were like okay
there's the ring and there's the book
The Diary of Tom Riddle and then it's
like something that belongs to uh
Gryffindor or um or uh Hufflepuff and
like something of ravenclaws like
everybody was speculating what the hor
CES were this is what it feels like with
the uh with the infinity
gems uh why did Thanos give the infinity
gem to Loki it makes sense I mean
I mean I Thanos okay here's the thing
you got to consider guys here's what you
got to
remember the problem was finding the
gyms for Thanos the problem wasn't
necessarily attaining the gyms like once
the gyms were discovered like once the
gyms were located I think that it
wouldn't be a problem for Thanos to take
them like I think what we're going to
see in Guardians of the Galaxy 2 or some
movie in between is that now the now
that the power gym is housed in uh in
xandar on xandar I think Thanos is going
to show up and just be like give me that
Gem and just take it and they're going
to try to stop him and he's going to be
like get the hell out of here and and
like he's literally just going to walk
in there beat the hell out of people no
one's going to be able to stop him and
he's just going to take the gym and
leave I think that's what's going to
happen but I don't
know uh which Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie or show are you most most
disappointed about
um I'm kind of disappointed with Marvel
with regards to Thor or I'm sorry with
uh The Incredible Hulk and the reason
why is because they're not going to do
anything with his character like the
Incredible Hulk got one movie with
Edward Norton which was a great movie I
thought like it was pretty good and uh
they're just never going to do anything
else with the Incredible Hulk I knew I
know that that um there was supposed to
be another movie that was going to be
made that was going to have going to be
a movie with Mark Ruffalo like it was
going to be a reboot of the Incredible
Hulk with Mark Ruffalo but they're not
going to as far as I understand they're
not going to give him his own movie
which sucks because Mark Ruffalo is an
amazing actor and they need to give him
his own movie for um for the incredible
Hulk like he's fantastic if you guys
ever saw blindness you guys need to go
see that movie like that movie is really
good that's one of Mark ruffalo's best
roles I think he's not even the main
star but he was just pretty
amazing uh let's
see did you like the Adam costume for
Arrow The Flash um I actually haven't
seen I I was actually starting that
episode of Arrow earlier or the flash
earlier and I stopped because I was like
you know I'll just wait until I have
time to watch the thing all the way
through yes I watch The Flash but um I
uh I saw pictures of it and and I don't
mind it I mean I think that some people
are might be a little more I think some
fans might be a little more traditional
in terms of what they like their outfits
to be like they don't want the atom to
wear they want the atam to wear like the
skin type blue outfit with the atom
symbol on the chest and I don't know but
um I think it kind of depends um what's
up with Age of Apocalypse did you stop
doing those BDS okay with Age of
Apocalypse and infinity Wars we've got
years to finish those like we we we've
got a whole bunch of stuff to do before
then we'll eventually get back to those
yes but we're not going to get back to
him right now so
um did you hear the new X-Men show
rumors of an xfactor type thing uh what
would you like them to do yeah I've
heard that they're going to make like a
I think like a new X-Men TV show or
something like that I've heard rumors um
at this point I thought it was only
rumors like they were they were toying
with the idea but they hadn't actually
like confirmed that it was going to
happen
um I don't know it'll never be X in the
Animated Series I'll say
that with Sony doing their old doing
their own thing do you think the will
take a crack at spiderverse maybe try
using
silk uh they don't own the rights to
Silk as far as I know they own the
rights to now here's see here's kind of
the kicker they own the rights to
Spider-Man and all the properties but
the question that I would ask is do they
own the rights to Spider-Man and all the
old properties and any new properties
that Marvel makes with regards to
Spider-Man if they don't then silk
belongs to Marvel they can add her in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't
know I would hope that Marvel wouldn't
be silly enough to sell the rights of a
character including all future ideas
that may come from that character I
would certainly hope not but you know I
me you never
know uh let's see could the Hulk wield
the Red Lantern ring Red Lantern power
ring of age of Rage how powerful would
he be who could defeat him I need to
know Rob I have no
idea I don't know if he could or not
uh who is your favorite Marvel character
and why mad Jim asper because he was the
first character that I ever read who had
the ability to warp reality and it just
stuck with me me I always I always loved
it um let's see God these these
questions are coming in so fast
um how do we win win the Omnibus is it
International in Europe actually
unfortunately I can't afford to ship
this thing to Europe so this is strictly
United States so I'm sorry for those of
you guys who are outside of the states
but this is strictly us
so
uh have you read Squirrel Girl if so
what did you think Squirrel Girl is is
it's like reading Deadpool it's a great
way to break the monotony of Marvel
Comics Squirrel Girl is a silly
character if you guys have read her
continuity she first showed up um and O
when did your first show up I don't
think it was Marvel preview maybe it was
Marvel preview number seven I don't
remember off top of my head but she
first showed up in some early comic and
then she like confronted Iron Man and
like ambushed Iron Man it was like I
want to be like a like a superhero like
I want to F alongside you and he was
like get out of here and then Iron Man
is held captive and like like she
actually defeats Dr Doom like she
succeeds in defeating Dr Doom and so
Iron Man's like okay you're not going to
be an Avenger but like I respect that
you're trying to be a superhero like I I
acknowledge your attempt to be a
superhero and then that was it but um
but as far as I know squirrel girl has
never lost a battle like whenever she
goes into conflict against an opponent
she actually killed Deadpool too which
as far as I understand it the way it was
done if I remember correctly she killed
Deadpool because or she was I guess yeah
I think she killed him before he was you
know came back healed himself or
whatever she killed him because she
created so many tiny scratches his body
didn't register them as injuries and so
it didn't actually like heal his body
and so he literally just bled to
death
uh let's
see it cost no extra okay we'll include
Canada but you know thoughts on Camila
Khan versus Miss Marvel I think CA
Khan's a great character I like the idea
of I like the idea of teenage
superheroes like I like ca Khan because
she's trying to become a superhero she's
trying to like fulfill the role that
Miss Marvel left vacant or I guess it
was kind of given to her by Miss
Marvel's former role but she still has
like Teenage problems and then she has
the problems that are compounded by like
the traditional traditional nature of
her parents and so she struggles like
every teenage kid does and I think
that's what makes it really kind of
interesting
um um you don't have to do anything to
win I'll just pick somebody at random at
the end of all
this
uh why do you wear headphones 24/7 I
don't know it's it's weird it's just
something I've always done I love
wearing
headphones
uh no I mean if you win like I'll pay to
ship it I'll just I'll ship it straight
out to
you
um people always ask what I mean I could
take them off if it bothers you guys I
mean I don't
care
uh a live action Red Hood movie
definitely like I would definitely watch
a live action red Hood movie I think it
would be
amazing uh let's see how old am I I am
30 years old it's kind of weird isn't it
like 30 years old talking about comic
books but then like I make YouTube
videos for a living and it's it's weird
but am I excited for civil war yes I'm
very excited for civil
war like I said I just don't know how
they're going to do it in one
movie uh worst Marvel character um
there was one character I don't remember
what his name is but he had uh he had
confronted the X-Men at some point in
time he had the ability to make force
fields and um he had fought Jean Gray I
think and somehow she had done something
I think to shut off his mind I don't
know if it was Gene gray it was somebody
but as a result like his forcefield got
stuck and um he suffocated inside of his
own force
field yeah I have
ears
oh man you don't have to do anything to
win all you have to do is just be
here uh what have you enjoyed about
reading DC so far all right this is a
really good question this is something I
have a meaning to
address all
right my dad was a huge DC guy like he
loved DC Comics he was raised on DC
Comics like he loved DC more than Marvel
and I was I was always a big Marvel
Comics fan but the more that I've been
reading DC especially new 52 the more I
realize I haven't been giving DC Comics
as proper due like DC Comics is pretty
solid in terms of its characters and and
you know how they try to figure stuff
out um I would say with the exception of
Superman a lot of the characters are
Dynamic but they're Dynamic and
comparison to Marvel characters now like
Marvel characters now aren't that
interesting like Cyclops like Cyclops
sucks nobody likes Cyclops now like
people used to love Cyclops because he
was always the guy Against All Odds he
would always lead the X-Men into
whatever whatever conflict it was it
didn't matter what it was he's like
we're going to get through this guys and
now he's just like I'm going to kill
Charles Xavier and just be an [__] to
everybody and like everybody hates him
like nobody likes Cyclops I mean Cyclops
there's a reason why Marvel never killed
off Cyclops and there was a reason why
Cyclops was always the leader of the
X-Men under Charles Xavier uh because he
was just a Mainstay he was always there
and he was a Legacy character that you
just never got rid of but Marvel somehow
managed to screw up that entire thing
and now people hate Cyclops I think that
DC characters in comparison to Marvel
Now are better characters more rich and
dynamic and more interesting but I still
think that Marvel has the better stories
so I don't know Batman is pretty badass
though I will say that optic blast uh do
you think there's any chance oh my God I
need to go back up
again do you think there's any chance of
a Howard the Duck movie in the future
because of the ending of Guardians of
the Galaxy I think Marvel I don't think
they're going to make a Guardians of the
I don't think they're going to make a
Howard the Duck film I think they're
actually bringing Howard the Duck Comics
back which
I'm not going to go by I wouldn't buy
how the duck Comics not at all I mean
I'd do a video on it if you guys really
wanted to see it but I wouldn't do a I
mean I wouldn't I wouldn't buy the
series like I wouldn't buy a how the
duck Omnibus but
um let's see Phoenix versus Thanos what
are your thoughts oh Phoenix would
easily destroy
Thanos I mean Phoenix would wipe wipe
the floor with him yeah if we're talking
about Cosmic empowered Thanos with The
Infinity Gauntlet well that just goes
without saying of course not there's
nothing Phoenix could do
but cover batch or Quinto as Doctor
Strange who do you have I have Hugh Lori
Hugh Lori should have been Marvel's only
choice for Dr strange but they chose not
to so that's
fine
uh that you really enjoy Days of Future
Past okay um rob you said in last week's
the weekly pool that you really enjoyed
Days of Future Past can you tell me how
it was that kitty was able to send
Wolverine into the past okay um it
wasn't
okay I don't know how Fox did this I
don't know why they did this I guess
maybe because they just didn't want to
introduce Rachel Summers I don't know
why but I just I guess they didn't want
to have to introduce a character they
would have to do something with later on
because they would have to explain her
character they'd have to tell the
audience because remember the audience
doesn't really know anything about Days
of Future Past they know of the concept
like a majority of people are like I
know of the days of future past and s
about time travel and like Xavier's dead
and like it's a dystopian future like
they know about the idea they just don't
know the specifics of it so if Fox had
made the Days of Future Past like it was
in the comic then they would have to
explain Franklin Richards and they would
have to explain Rachel Summers they'd
have to make something know they could
do it really fast and just say somewhere
along the line Scott Summers and Jee
gray had a daughter and that's who she
is now done and done and people would be
like oh okay well that makes sense and
that would have been it you know and
they would have said you know she has
telepathic abilities or something like
that but the way that that kitty Pride
was able to do it was by apparently
manipulating her ability to phase
through matter by phasing through the
time stream or something like that now
why it is that wol rain had to go into
the past I think was it was a stretch by
saying well he can heal his mind and so
like that's why he has to go because he
has to go back a significant amount of
time that doesn't make any sense like to
me that's stupid I mean when it comes to
the idea of time travel in Marvel Comics
those of you guys who have been reading
this for years and years and years know
there's no difference between jumping a
year into the past or jumping 300 years
into the past it's opening a portal and
walking through that's it it doesn't
matter and so that's why I think they
kind of screwed it up by doing it the
way they did because it it's it was
nonsense it was just a way to get
Wolverine to be the one to go into the
past and make him the star of a film
that he shouldn't have been the star of
so
uh let's
see how far am I into Arrow I completely
caught up with
arrow which arrow is
amazing
Ant-Man versus The Vision you guys come
up with some of the weirdest the
weirdest things like you guys come up
with weird stuff um what are you
expecting to see on the Civil War movie
okay I recognize a lot of you guys are
new here oh my um my PS4 gamertag is
Marvel explained by the way it's all
lowercase so like like add me I might be
playing like Destiny later on tonight
and add me if you're going to be on
Destiny and uh we'll play later
on
um yeah that's tyan Lannister security
system that was funny um okay so anyway
going back to that initial initial
question what am I expecting to see in
uh in um in Civil War all
right here's what I think Marvel's going
to do with Civil War and I I know a lot
of you guys again are new to my channel
and so you didn't get a chance to see
this discussion that we had with civil
war or with h with with Civil War and
the discussion about what Marvel's going
to do with civil war in the podcast what
I think Marvel's going to do here is is
Captain America 3 Civil War is going to
lay the foundation because the question
you have to ask is if Marvel is doing
Infinity Wars or basically The Infinity
Gauntlet story line at the end of phase
four I guess it is or or whatever it is
like when that's that's the big event
like that's going to be the big thing
that's going to wrap up this group of
phases and then they're going to move on
to the next group of phases then what do
they do after that and so I think what's
going to happen here is Marvel I guess
like Captain America 3 Civil War is
going to plant the seeds that's going to
Tony Stark and Iron Man conflicting
that's going to be them like just kind
of butting heads and saying okay look
like we don't agree on things like Tony
slark saying look there needs to be
registration for superheroes Captain
America saying no there doesn't like
they just need to be able to do their
own thing like we should be the one to
police our own it shouldn't be the
federal government that does it and they
certainly shouldn't have to register
because that's the way it always was
superheroes police their own like they
they took care of their own they didn't
contract out to the federal government
to do it and then what I think's going
to happen is they're going to bump heads
they're probably going to be maybe a
fight or something like that something
else going on and I think what Mar's
going to do is they're going to plant
the seeds and so over the course of the
remainder of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe stories leading up to Infinity
War we're going to see little events
happen we're going to see little spurts
here and there we're Captain America and
Iron Man will get into an argument where
we'll hear we'll watch the news and see
something that happened or something
like that like there'll be a scene where
where Tony Stark is watching the news
and something happens or like he'll be
testifying in front of Congress about
the registration act or the possibility
of registration and then once the
infinity War event comes to an end then
in the next phase is when we'll see the
equivalent of nitro blowing up Stanford
Connecticut and then it'll be bam Civil
War and it'll all kick in the reason why
is because right now there's just not
enough time there's not enough
characters to really make the Civil War
worth watching I mean if they if they
did Civil War in one movie and they just
split the Avengers down the middle I
mean I wouldn't really care I mean Black
Widow versus Hawkeye we've seen that
like Thor versus the Incredible Hulk I
mean you know like I don't care about
that like Civil War was a good story
because of the political Dynamic of it
that's what made it a good story the
politics that's what made it cool I mean
superheroes fight each other all the
time that was that was not anything we
hadn't seen before I mean I guess it was
a huge epic battle which you know to a
degree was cool but to me it was the
politics it was the underlying themes of
civil war that made it interesting not
the great big huge explosions fights at
the end
so
uh let's
see why does Spider-Man hate Deadpool
because Deadpool's annoying as hell
that's why
uh what story arc do you want to see in
the film again this this the the story
that I want to see the most is I want to
see a stretched out Civil War like I
want to see a civil war series that
covers like 10 movies that's what I want
to
see
uh do you think that Ant-Man will in any
way have something to do with creating
Ultron not to my knowledge to my
knowledge it's all Tony Stark that's all
going to be he's he's the only reason
why Ultron gets
created
[Music]
uh I was disappointed with Civil War
more characters should have died a ton
of people died during Civil War who else
do you think should have
died oh a good director for Captain
Marvel um get the chick that did the
woman that did um Zero Dark 30 I can't
remember what her name is but she's
she's an amazing
director uh oops let's let's scroll back
up again like these questions are coming
in so fast we got to scroll up like two
or three questions to them all um do you
think Agents of Shield will make an
appearance in an upcoming Marvel
Cinematic Universe movie definitely
they'll appear at some point like Marvel
will find some way to wrap the Agents of
Shield into the actual films that way
it'll give it like a completeness
because I think that right now like you
have Agents of Shield on the TV show but
I think people still feel there's like
this disconnect between what goes on in
the movies and what goes on in the TV
show if they bring the agents of shields
the Agents of Shield into the movies and
they have like sky and they have like
agent May and all those people I I think
it'll complete the story and it'll make
it a little more interesting
so uh let's
see Hulk Hulk versus Hulkbuster fight in
Age of Ultron thoughts well my thought
here is that Hulk's going to be under
some measure of mind control or
something like that going to be mentally
manipulated and this is what I think is
going to lead into them kicking the
Incredible Hulk off of the planet Earth
I know they're not going to do like a
planet Hulk thing like I think they
might they'll kick him off the planet
Earth though they won't cover what the
Incredible Hulk is doing the Incredible
Hulk will come back and he'll say here's
what happened while I was gone and now
like I'm going to beat the [__] out of
all of you like I think that's what
what's going to happen but um I think
that he's going to be I think that that
it'll just be some measure of mind
control that Ultron implements or that
the Scarlet Witch implements because his
eyes are red he's got red rings around
his eyes and I think we might even see
the gray The Grey Hulk there so I don't
know I mean I think it all really kind
of depends
but what have you enjoyed the most Arrow
or the flash uh Arrow definitely like I
I think arrow is a more Dynamic show but
the flash is still pretty interesting
too
uh which countries do you ship to uh the
United States and
Canada could carage attach himself to
Red Hulk I mean the Carnage symia could
attach himself to anything it doesn't
matter what it is I well anything with
sentience like any kind of a being he
could definitely attach himself to the
Red Hulk imagine that imagine the Red
Hulk with a Carnage symbiot like running
around killing people it would be
absolute
pandemonia
uh what are your thoughts on the
Daredevil trailer again we had this
discussion earlier we were talking about
the Daredevil trailer and and I think
that this Daredevil Netflix series is
going to follow Frank Miller's run of
Daredevil which is a pretty lengthy run
and is considered by me to be the best
run but do I think Shield will come back
in Captain America 3 yes I think Shield
will come back and it'll be headed up by
Maria Hill but I don't
know do I think they're rushing the
Inhumans by putting them in Agents of
Shield not at all I think that putting
the Inhumans in Agents of Shield is a
great way to segue the Inhumans into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the problem is
that if they brought the Inhumans into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe doing a
movie they would have to do something
with them I guess maybe they could do
like a 30second trailer or you know a
30-second preview at the end but people
would expect to see an in hum's movie
relatively soon they couldn't say like
here's a 30-second trailer for the movie
and the movie's coming out in four years
like they couldn't do that like they
they'd have like I think segueing them
in is great because what it does is it
gives them time to to to let like the
plot for what the Inhumans movie will be
develop organically as as they're
writing the episodes of Agents of Shield
then involve the Inhumans we can get
more of an idea of what the Inhumans are
about and ultimately be introduced to
the Inhumans in uh in the film now
here's the question that I would ask if
Vin Diesel is going to play blackbolt is
he going to be an Agents of Shield are
we going to see Vin Diesel in like one
episode of Agents of Shield because if I
were Marvel I would do that I would say
have Vin Diesel have like the Agents of
Shield visit blackbolt or visit the uh
the city of aellen like where the royal
family
resides they're captured by by like
other Inhumans or something like that
and like they bring them before
blackbolt and black Bolt's like why are
you here and they're like well we just
kind of stumbled along this place or I
guess Medusa speaking for blackbolt
would be like why are you here and
they're like well we just kind of
stumbled in here like we didn't know
what this was like we'll get out of here
and and medus is like if you don't leave
like Black Bolt is going to kill you and
that's it like that's it's a five minute
clip and that that's all you see of IND
diesel for until you see the movie and
and that's what I would do i' if I
Marvel I would be like look dude we'll
pay you an exorbitant amount of money
for this one scene I don't care what it
is like just be here for like this one
scene a of shield and it'd be a great
way to segue to really tie it all
together
but uh Nicholas Cage is black pulled
you're God
no terog Genesis is it covered by my
Healthcare uh
no what's the next character you do a
Marvel Comics explanation on um we'll
probably do Phil Coulson um or Daredevil
I haven't decided yet but we'll do one
of them one of the two of them in the
next day or two it might be Phil cson
first and then Daredevil next I'm not
really sure
but
uh will sword appear in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe okay for those of you
guys who don't know what sword is sword
is a really cool
concept sword operates separate from
Shield sword is the sentient World
observation and response Department I
think I'm not going to swear to that but
I'm pretty sure that's what it is and
it's headed up
by oh God one of you guys in the chat
tell me what her name is I can't
remember her name um but
um we I think we'll see them at some
point in time like once because of the
fact we've introduced like xandar into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I think
sword will be introduced now I think
what Marvel will do is it will introduce
sword as a branch of Shield but
nonetheless I'm I'm kind of curious to
see how they do it but I think we'll see
sword at some point along the
line uh
do you think that instead of cosmic
beings the Earth's heroes are going to
take out Thanos or are they going to
introduce the cosmic beings I don't know
I'm really not sure um I would like to
see them introduce Cosmic beings but
again like a lot of these some of these
Cosmic beings like Galactus they can't
have because he's a fantastic for
character Abigail bran that's who it is
thank you
guys but um but Galactic we can't have
but like eternity
first appeared in uh in a doctor strange
comic um and the Living Tribunal
appeared in a doctor strange comic like
a lot of these characters found their
origins in Doctor Strange comics and so
I think that they should introduce these
characters in and then just kind of go
from there but again I don't know
uh
which which inhuman do you do I think
Raina will be I think Raina will be
Raina of the
Inhumans
uh when are they going to bring
crossbones uh bringing crossbone since
he was in Captain America 2o maybe even
Baron
Zemo I think crossbones will appear in
Captain America
3 like as crossbones I think that's what
we'll actually see him I don't
know
uh
if Batman versus Superman does
good do I think that DC automatically
Catches Up movie wise no not at all
because they don't have a cohesive
Universe with their
films they're all totally separate and
exists in isolation from one
another
uh thoughts on moonight do you want to
see him in the MCU movie or Netflix I'd
love to see Mark Spectre in some of
those films I mean I think he'd be
better relegated to Netflix because he
has he has a cult following among comic
book fans but other people in the
mainstream have no idea who he is if
they brought in moonnight to a film they
would say like isn't that Batman like
that's what a lot of people would say so
I don't know yeah Captain crossbow is
confirmed for Civil War I don't know I
really hope they have doramu and Doctor
Strange I don't think they will I think
Doctor Strange's villain will be will be
um MTO I think that'll be the villain
that he goes against or or they may not
they may not even do an for his
character he may just be there I don't I
don't really know yet but
um I think that uh I don't
know they should mention doramu or have
some discussion about doramu I don't
think they be a villain in the doctor
strange film I mean could you imagine
that they go from 0 to 60 it would be
like well here's doctor strange and
here's like the most powerful demon
entity to ever exist in the history of
Marvel Comics who exists in like a demon
realm like let's just have them fight
each other it would be absolutely nuts
but uh
am I drinking the Tony Stark special no
I'm
not I'm getting crunk I'm drinking
Hooch Rob do you have a favorite
character in Marvel yeah mad Jim Jaspers
shag gorath I'm not gonna do a video on
schag
gorath will agent 13 kill Captain
America like in Civil War comic like in
the Civil War comic I don't know I think
so I think it'd be a great
twist but again there was a lot of
buildup under Ed brubaker's run for
agent 13 killing Captain America at the
end of uh at the end of Civil War so I
don't
know
uh which is the worst movie Ghost Rider
or Daredevil uh they equally suck
although the Daredevil director's cut
wasn't bad Nathan fillian is quazar no I
don't I love Nathan Filan but I don't
want to see him as
quazar
[Music]
uh Spider-Man and the Marvel movies did
you guys not see the Spider-Man
announcement for from uh the Super
Bowl I thought Sur you guys saw that
like Marvel had a Spider-Man
announcement during a civil war or
during the Super
Bowl I'm messing
[Laughter]
around uh will Marvel lose Robert Downey
Jr after Civil War I don't know as far
as I understand he was tied on for a set
number of films those films will expire
before civil war ends but I think it's
up in the air whether or not he's going
to return I think the problem or the
fear that Robert Downey Jr has and I
don't doubt him for this is that he
doesn't want to be typ cast like he's
been a lot of different characters over
the years but I think that I think that
like Cil I think that that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that him playing Iron
Man there was a lot of catharsis
involved in that for him like it was
basically him rebuilding his career and
rebuilding his life in a lot of ways um
but I think that that with him he's a
very diverse actor and he can do a lot
of different things if I were him I
wouldn't want to be relegated to being
like to being Tony Stark like I wouldn't
want people to look at me and to see
Tony Stark like that's the problem you
have like Mark Hamill people look at
Mark Hamill and they see uh Luke
Skywalker you know people look at Daniel
rackliffe and they see Harry Potter like
I wouldn't want to be in that role
either so I mean that was one of the big
things like when the uh the judge came
out the movie The Judge a lot of people
were saying like he was great in this
but not as good as Iron Man and that's
what that's what I think he's trying to
avoid
so oh
man I made you guys look it up
[Music]
uh what time frame is X-Men apocalypse
going to take place and I think it's
going to take place in like the 80s I
think I'm not going to swear to that but
I think it
will
uh could Toby McGuire still plays
Spider-Man no if if Marvel gets the
rights of Spider-Man back for example
and they decide to reboot it they don't
need Andrew Garfield or Toby McGuire I
think Andrew Garfield was a great
Spider-Man and I would love to see him
return under Marvel but Marvel would be
better off just like wiping the slight
clean and starting over and picking like
totally new characters to play the role
of Spider-Man so I don't blame them for
saying they don't want him to play that
role do I think Fox's fantastic Force
should fail so that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe gets key figures like Dr Doom
and galatis yeah like it needs to fail
it needs to fail so that fox will just
give up and say okay fine like here is
the Fantastic forb
back
uh do I enter a room like Doom does
busting through the
wall no I
don't like a
peasant uh Rob least favorite comic book
event or event you feel can have been
better
uh there's a lot of events that it could
have been better maximum security for
example was just like a silly event it
basically ended up with the Earth being
turned into a prison planet and running
the accuser overseeing it like it was it
was silly I think they should that I
thought I thought it was
done Aaron Paul for Spider-Man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe no
way not by a long
shot Aaron Paul's always going to be
Jesse like he's always gonna be Jesse
from uh Jesse Pinkman he's gonna be
Jesse Pinkman from Breaking
Bad I'm 30 30 years
[Music]
old uh let's
see
Rob for Adam Warlock why would I play
Adam
[Laughter]
Warlock
uh is it true the actor playing Winter
Soldier sign up for nine movies would he
take up the Captain America man that's
what I think is going to happen it's a
Sebastian Stan and I think it's yeah
Sebastian Stan I think is his name um
but yeah he's he's supposed to play like
a ton of movies and I think that he's is
going to take over the role of Captain
America but he might not I think that
Marvel was looking at this idea and then
they came along and said let's make
Falcon the new Captain America and
people were like well I mean I guess you
know and that was it I'm curious what do
you guys think about Falcon as the new
Captain America like let's reverse this
Q&A for a moment like what do you guys
think about Falcon playing
cap will B Ray Bill be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe would you like that
to happen I wouldn't be adverse to it I
mean I wouldn't be against it uh you
know not really sure how I'd feel about
it but I wouldn't be I wouldn't be angry
about it if that's what you're
asking ever think about doing a local
fan meet up near you uh yeah but I don't
think I'm really big enough to do like a
local fan meet up or all you know it'd
be cool but I don't think I'm big enough
for you know like hey guys let's all go
meet
up
uh modok no
way Rob for the one above
all
now people are just like saying stuff
people are just like like shouting
stuff Winter
Soldier oh
man you guys crack me up Dr Doom versus
Doctor
Strange Doctor Strange
definitely there were actually a series
of runs where it was doom and strange
but
uh what do I think
spiderverse
H that's all
right uh let's
see oh oops I moved the
mouse all right
um we're going to do this about another
another half an hour and then um I'm
going to go ahead and give this thing
away and then bring this to an end but
um do you think cos comic events Civil
Wars secret Wars original sin are
becoming less important and impacting
since they do so many one right after
another yes that's the problem that is
the problem with tiin I'm sorry with
with big events big events big
crossovers are cool when they're rare
when they happen only once in a while
like once every year or so because then
it gives you the feeling that there's
this great big huge expanded universe
outside of what you've been reading all
this time but um when they happen all
the time it takes away from the
interesting nature because you don't
really have time to focus and even then
it gets confusing I mean you have like
the captain like you've got Captain
Falcon you've got multiple stories going
on with Captain Falcon right now you've
got Captain Falcon fear Him you've got
Captain Falcon's uh I guess all new
Captain America solo series you had
Captain America going on in axis you had
all these different things going on and
people were like I don't know what to do
here like I don't know where to start
like characters need to have their own
solo Series teams need to have their own
solo series and then big crossover
events need to happen every once in a
while the problem is that big crossover
events make a lot of money like they
sell a lot of comics and so people you
know marvel will keep doing it marel
will stop doing crossover events as
often as they do when people stop buying
them as much which is actually what
they're starting to see
so
uh do I think clo and Dagger will make
an appearance in the MCU I guess but I
don't think it really matters they may
or they may
not which by the way I need to pull up
Twitter we've been doing this for an
hour and I haven't answered any of my
Twitter questions I think let's
see
Twitter oh wow oh nobody asked me any
questions on Twitter okay well that's
fine oh
man
uh would I like to see Spider-Man movies
if Marvel gets the right back definitely
I'd love to see what Marvel would do
Voldemort versus Iron
Man ah it'd be
Voldemort
I should work with Marvel Marvel's
YouTube channel
sucks I
mean I'd work for Marvel and a heartbeat
if Marvel came to me and said we want
you to do what you do on your channel
now but we want you to do it on our
Channel and we'll pay you to do it like
I would do that like with no questions
asked I would be like okay I'm
down that'd be
awesome
uh would you like to see the Sentry in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah yeah
definitely like that would be
awesome make some versus videos like
Superman versus Hulk with more details
it would be
fun I mean back in the day they used to
have a lot of those like I think that
you know we might do that like we might
do that at some point later on in the
future in the next you know months and
five or six months or something like
that we might do like Marvel versus DC
that'd be kind of
cool
uh
have you kept up with the Hawkeye run I
found volume two a bit disappointing so
far and the overemphasis on West Coast
Hawkeye is boring for as boring me I
really haven't been following up with
Hawkeye solo series honestly I don't
really care much about Hawkeye to follow
his own solo series it just doesn't
really matter to
me Squirrel Girl versus
cord you me like Franklin
Richards
oh Jake lionhardt just posted on my
Twitter oh man well everybody sending me
questions on Twitter
now oh
man
uh so the timeline being fixed in the
future does that mean all the characters
basically
survive that's what it would seem that's
why it's a stupid idea for them to do
for them to have gone back and fixed
that that's why like like Fox doesn't
pay attention to what they do like fox
says like let's do this like they have
to Recon themselves like let's do a and
then at the end of a they show a preview
for B but they're like well God this
preview conflicts with our plans for C
so you know whatever that's the
problem
uh what's my view on Lobo
oh hi
Vapes I would love to see the Shadow
King in a nextmen
movie
uh he did it I commanded him and he did
it I follow the commands of Alec
winsler I do what Alec wisler tells me
to
uh he now rules
Marvel what is a good trade to get for
them oh you love the Fantastic 4 if you
like the Fantastic 4 get Mark Wade's run
of the Fantastic 4 and get Jonathan
Hickman's run of the Fantastic 4 those
are excellent stories they're incredibly
awesome likewise for those of you guys
who have watched the uh the Daredevil
thing and I and like I said I'm G to
start posting like reading orders for a
lot of the characters because I know a
lot of you guys are curious a lot of you
guys have Marvel unlimited or a lot of
you guys um are thinking about getting
Marvel unlimited again you should have
Marvel unlimited at this point so you
can go through and read a bunch of these
stories and stuff but um I think I'm
going to start posting reading orders so
you guys can go through and uh and start
watching um finally you're looking at
Twitter um I've been looking at Twitter
man what is this what in the heck I've
been looking at Twitter
uh but
um what was I talking
about oh yeah yeah I think I'm going to
start posting um uh reading orders so
you guys can go through and decide what
it is that you want to do oh my God like
Twitter's blowing up now I never should
have said anything about
Twitter
uh oh God this is a good question if
lightsabers are powered by crystals
would Darth Vader or Luke with
Kryptonite Crystal saber be able to take
Superman yeah yeah they could I would
say so I
mean the crystals emit their properties
into the light lightsaber itself so I'd
say probably
so where do I start with Marvel oh my
God I knew somebody was going to ask
this
question somebody was going to ask this
question where do I start with Marvel
Comics
okay if what you're wanting to do is to
read Marvel Comics don't watch me on
your cell phone like drive like don't be
watching me while you're driving you're
going to get new a car wreck and get
hurt um God I got to think about this
for a
[Music]
second where to start with Marvel
okay there are some characters that you
don't really have to start that far back
with some of the characters are really
really simple the origins of Spider-Man
are a Timeless story everybody knows how
Spider-Man became Spider-Man that he was
bitten by a radioactive spider done and
done he fought some people some stuff
happened and it leads up to the current
continuity at the moment
um this is a question best answered
character by character so I would say
this might be a good series you know
what we should do that I think we might
start that instead of instead of doing
like Phil Coulson and
Daredevil we'll just do we'll do that we
should we should do this that's that's a
great idea we're going to start a series
called where to start and we're going to
be like where to start Daredevil where
to start you know Captain Marvel where
to start like that would be that's an
awesome idea for a series see that's
that's why I love you guys cuz you guys
come up with awesome
ideas oh man all right
uh would I ever do a setup a setup video
or a room tour I want to see what your
setup looks like I mean my setup's not
that great like it's a computer desk
with a external sound card and some
microphones and the headphones you guys
are giveing me a hard time about and and
that's it like my Marvel lights you guys
are my Marvel lights that's what you
guys are that's that's what you guys you
guys are my Marvel
lights oh man so that that's that's what
we're going to do you guys
I like how moonman 4000 he's like we're
so
awesome like we're so amazing I sound
like James Earl
Jones um but that's that's a great idea
guys yeah we're going to do that where
to start that's where to start Daredevil
and all and all I'm going to do is I'm
going to say like if you guys want to
start with Daredevil like here's where
you should start and why like here's the
significance of this writer's run of
Daredevil here's the significance of
that writer's run of Daredevil here's
what happened over the continuity of
writers like that that's an awesome idea
I have to give a little more thought to
actually like flesh out the idea but
yeah
um you said on one of your earlier
weekly pools that you don't like The
Runaways why do you dislike awesomeness
you know whatever
that's The Runaways aren't awesome and
The Runaways never
were The Runaways were never awesome
okay here you guys in the chat answer
this question were The Runaways ever
awesome was there ever a point when The
Runaways were cool like somebody answer
that question for
me oh I'm all out of water
no
uh where to start
Wikipedia yeah I probably have to remake
those videos after Secret Wars well no
no okay so here's the thing guys like
keep this in mind guys a lot of people
seem to forget this the histories of the
characters are going to stay the same
Peter Parker's continuity is still going
to date all the way back to the 1960s
the origins of the X-Men are still going
to stay the same all this happening is
that like a lot of characters are being
killed off and a lot of realities are
coming to fruition stuff like that the
characters Origins are going to remain
the same it's just the the the
circumstance we're going to be in it's
just going to be different like it's
just going to be a little separate
so uh The Runaways are dumb see Alec
Windsor knows what I'm talking about
runaways are dumb The Runaways were
never cool
uh do I think the beyonder Kill The
Living Tribunal okay you know you guys
have been have been hassling me about
this question which makes sense because
I'm Marvel explained I explain stuff I
make it makes sense who killed the
Living Tribunal
okay in new of in New Avengers issue
number eight number 10 can't remember
off top of my head Tony Stark is called
to the Moon by The Watcher and when Tony
Stark arrives The Living Tribunal is
laying dead on the moon and his corpse
is all shriveled up and no one knows who
did it there's not like no one knows who
did it all right the Living Tribunal
exists as a multiversal entity meaning
that there's only one of him even though
there's a Multiverse The Living Tribunal
is second only to the one above all
therefore it makes perfect sense the one
above all killed the Living Tribunal now
we don't know that we don't know if some
some developed some kind of a weapon
that could sa the power of the Living
Tribunal that could physically eliminate
the Living Tribunal we don't know and
and that's that's the thing here we
don't know anything about this rabu
malal character which seems to be the
one that killed the Living Tribunal
Jonathan Hickman has said rabu malal is
a brand new character someone we've
never seen before and it could very well
be that this this version this character
is a character that exists on par with
the one above all that's just as
powerful as a one above all we don't
know all we know is that somebody killed
the Living Tribunal and Marvel hasn't
told us who it is so
[Music]
uh let me
lose that's Hickman no answers only
questions that is that is that is to
Blake that is Jonathan Hickman perfect
Blake knows exactly what I'm talking
about uh Alec Windsor is famous Alec
Windsor you are
famous I kill the Living
Tribunal that that is the secret I
killed I killed
muasa
oh
man
uh Swamp Thing versus man thing I mean I
don't I don't
know squirrel girl killed a Living
Tribunal there we go she just scratched
him to death and he he died and that was
it oh
man will there be more Deadpool specials
yes I'm trying to spread out the
Deadpool videos I don't want to Clump
all the Deadpool videos together I think
that's kind of a problem is all the
Deadpools being like clumped together
are just kind of like well I mean you
know I don't know where just I don't
know what to do I don't know people will
get burned out on Deadpool you know
Deadpool kills Deadpool is decent enough
but there's also some really good runs
in like Deadpool solo series like
Deadpool MK with a mouth is a series of
stories that are just freaking awesome
like they're really really good and it'd
be fun
so
H will The Summer Event make it easier
to get into Marvel Comics it's supposed
to but we're not sure and that's why I
want to why I want to launch that where
to start series because it'll make
things make
sense Adam extreme versus way too many
sorts uh are you going to do another
video like the Dr Doom walks into a room
like a boss yeah I'll do another one of
those eventually but that was just fun
it was just a fun one-off thing that
that I just I felt like doing I was up
at like 5:00 in the morning when I
thought of that idea I was like you know
we should do something like I should do
something like this and in truth it was
actually an idea that was inspired by um
by by comic Drake which if you guys
don't follow comic Drake you should but
he had this idea where he acted like he
him and a bunch of people acted out
characters from a Martian Manhunter
story where I think he was trying to
find like a like a banana or something
like that I can't remember what it was
but but yeah make sure you guys check
out comic Drake on here on
YouTube there seems to be absolutely no
point to original original sin thoughts
Rob that's true there really is no point
to Original Sin original sin was a way
from Marvel to segue from one event to
another it was a way for them to
introduce stories they wanted to
introduce that's really all it was it
was just the problem that Marvel had is
they wanted to go from a to c but they
didn't have a b and so they said well
let's just do original sin and it'll
give us B and that's how they did it so
but it was also a way for them to get
rid of characters they didn't want to do
anything with too like it was a way for
them to take Nick Fury and just send
Nick Fury off to the moon and now we
haven't seen Nick Fury since like we
have no idea what's going on with Nick
Fury he's presumably just sitting on the
moon chained there watching everything
happen and that's it he's the new
Watcher that's all he does is just sit
on the moon and watch
um it may be that he'll come back at
some point in time if he is the Watcher
this is where I would say he could
really be brought back in a cool way if
he is the Watcher and The Watcher saw
everything in the Multiverse maybe Nick
Fury saw who killed the Living Tribunal
more so than that maybe Nick Fury knows
who were boal is and it'd be a great way
to bring Nick Fury back into the Marvel
Universe but I doubt they
will uh do you believe they're going to
bring Scrolls into the Marvel movies I
don't think they have the rights to
scroll to the Scrolls no maybe they do I
don't
know uh yeah original sin wasn't the
greatest story ever it was a really
really cool leadup and then it was like
a bunch of fizzle it just and that was
it
uh molecule
man uh yeah I think Stanley's is the
Watcher in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
why wouldn't he
be Hil
Hydra
uh I am Nick
Fury
can Benedict Cumberbatch steal the show
for Marvel yes Benedict Cumberbatch is
an amazing show like patches is awesome
at everything he does um patches
actually I was on um a podcast with uh
with Alex I can't remember how to
pronounce his last name but um but
anyway it was it was a really cool
podcast and I'll post a link um in the
description of this Channel or in the
description of this video when we're
done with the done with this um live
stream but um one of the people on there
was talking about uh about Benedict
Cumberbatch and she was saying that
people couldn't like pronounce his last
name and so there's like all these
Tumblr Pages where people are just like
posting all these ridiculous versions of
what his last name would be and one of
the ones that's stuck was patches and so
I always call Benedict Cumberbatch
patches uh verbal
diarrhea okay guys so we we' we've it's
we've been doing this for almost an hour
and a half or so
um let's decide who gets this thing
let's decide who
gets this
precious this precious
Omnibus
um I think it's fun that I can do stuff
like this you know and I think
that that eventually oh my God is
Twitter freaking blowing up 84 84
comments on Twitter my God
notifications
Jesus
um I think it's awesome that I have the
opportunity to do stuff like
this I think it's awesome that I have
the chance to give things
away
um and so I appreciate that you guys
have been so supportive throughout this
whole YouTube channel I appreciate that
that I've been experimenting trying new
ideas which it just that's that's just
that's the nature of YouTube one of the
most difficult things to do with YouTube
is to stay ahead of the curve like bny
will tell you like I walked into this
whole YouTube thing and had no idea what
I was doing
and and Benny's like really been helping
me out in a lot of ways and like
understanding how YouTube works and he's
also been like dude that's that's a
boneheaded decision you shouldn't do
that and things like that but
nonetheless you know it's it's been like
a really big learning experience and so
um I love the idea that I can do stuff
like this that I can give things away
and and have fun with this whole YouTube
thing
so
um yeah yeah also if you guys are
interested I don't know if you guys if
you guys care it all but I mean I've got
a patreon you know which uh it's it's uh
let's see let me make sure but it
is yeah patreon.com Marvel expained is
my patreon page so if you guys want to
you guys are welcome to go there and and
you know and do what patreon does you
know donate or whatever but uh again
it's it's don't don't ever feel as
though you have to that's that's totally
an unnecessary thing you know I don't
want you guys to feel as though I'm you
guys need to it's just if you guys feel
so inclined that's awesome nonetheless
so get to the important stuff stuff that
matters giving this away
so who do we give it away
to uh I'm not going to give it to
Benny
uh uh oh
man I'm scrolling through comments right
now to
see
okay we're GNA give this to Michael
Edwards Michael Edwards you officially
win this uh this Deadpool and cable
Omnibus it is yours so send me a message
um at my email
um or can send me a message here on
YouTube would be the best way to do it
and um and I'll get with you on a I I'll
just we'll go from there but I'll get
your your address and um and we'll uh we
we I'll get it mailed out to you
so anyway um so yeah so yeah that's uh
that's it
oh man but uh but yeah so I just before
I get off here um I just want to say I
love you guys you guys are amazing um
you guys are you guys are are fantastic
um I never thought we'd make it to
150,000 subscribers like I never in a
million years thought we'd make it but
we did and because of that you know it
has really
become this in incredible experience
like this incredible Road of just
traveling this incredible Road of of
just meeting new people and having this
cool experience and talking to you guys
and doing these live streams and the
podcast and making these videos and it's
just been it's been unbelievable like
I've enjoyed every minute of this and
and here's to 300,000 hopefully we'll
make it to 300,000 one day after that
it'll be five and maybe if we have our
fingers
crossed maybe we'll make it to a million
one day I don't know but um but for
right now you know I want to say that
that you know you guys are fantastic
that you guys are unbelievable and that
I appreciate every ounce of support that
you guys have given me so far so anyway
um yeah that's it so I guess we'll go
ahead and and and bring this uh bring
this live stream to an end I'll catch
you guys later and uh and Michael
Edwards don't forget to send me a
message peace